despite the security threat there is a
flurry of activity on capitol hill today
the senate could soon debate a new covet
economic relief bill
after president biden agreed to a
compromise that limits who will be
eligible for those stimulus checks
in the house the democrats have passed a
landmark new voting rights bill
nancy cordes and ed o'keefe are all over
this story we're going to start with
nancy on covert relief
which is really what a lot of people are
wondering about right now
nancy good morning to you what did the
president agree to
gail the horse trading is over the
president and senate democrats have
agreed to keep those 1400
checks in place but the number of people
who could receive them
has been paired back slightly so who
gets the checks
well individuals making up to seventy
five thousand dollars
or a year or less would get the full
amount but then
smaller checks would start to go to
people making up to eighty thousand
dollars a year
married couples who make up to a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars will get
twenty hundred twenty eight hundred
dollars for a couple and then fourteen
hundred dollars additional
for each child smaller checks would then
go to couples
making up to a combined one hundred
sixty thousand dollars
all this means that about nine million
households that got stimulus checks
last year will not get them this time
around but we're still talking about
roughly 150 million households in this
country
that will get a check and it'll actually
be a little bigger than it was the last
time
the senate is expected to hold its first
procedural vote on all this today
but republicans are still arguing they
think this package is too big it's not
targeted enough and they are vowing
to draw the process out as long as they
can
got it nancy thank you very much